[Música]
bienvenidos a cultural desde casa la
pandemia ha hecho que ésta sea set sala
de cine y librería online todo-en-uno
pero hay algo que no ha podido trastocar
y es un 2020 de buena y abundante música
que suene así
[Música]
y haga bailar de este otro modo
lady gaga desde eeuu y dsiware desde
reino unido son dos de cinco artistas
que han profetizado que íbamos a sentir
nostalgia y vamos a necesitar un tiempo
mejor así que este año han recuperado un
baile y una música disco que sin duda ha
encabezado kylie minogue la australiana
hasta ha nombrado su álbum así que va
seguido de los consolidados de web y
gaga esta última noventera y de los
innovadores de dual y pain miley cyrus
con género más actualizado ya está
fusionado
[Música]
para muchos el quinteto ha rescatado
nuestra vitalidad por separado y con
alguna colaboración entre sí como el
lipa y cyrus lo de la dibam y no es un
viaje pop a los 70 y 80 mientras que
cyrus se llena de esa estética y ese
sonido house y dance no vivido para
liberarse como un pájaro dice mención
aparte para dual y para que logre atraer
esa energía pasada al futuro para ser
una diva más actual
[Música]
la música es nuestro hilo hoy y al
coreógrafo médica q se le ha conllevado
una fortuna personal la de llevar el hip
hop a la ópera de parís su hazaña se
origina en el primer confinamiento
gracias a un vídeo que catapultó su
danza recaudó dinero para hospitales
capitalinos y le llevó a la propuesta de
crear un espectáculo en el palacio
garnier la coreografía de 20 minutos
combina danza contemporánea y hip hop
pero sobre todo es para este joven de
origen argentino una felicidad suprema y
el sueño cumplido de niños
ya en clave de cine suena centroamérica
y el caribe porque la guatemalteca la
llorona se ha erigido como cinta para
entrar en los oscar con una trama de un
exmilitar que se salva de ser condenado
genocida salvo que en su mente y tras la
llegada de una joven empleada empiezan a
retumbar las voces de los indígenas que
mató a la vez que un fantasma busca
venganza por esa comunidad
y
lo que se quedó atrás
en otro sentido un poco fantasma es el
papi al que da ritmo la dominicana rita
indiana cuya novela de igual título ha
alcanzado la pantalla es la boricua
noelia quintero quien dirige y adapta a
esta obra que es como un rap que trata
sobre una niña de cultura pop que
siempre espera a su papi un mafioso que
va y viene que vive en nueva york' iba
cargado de dinero regalos y novias pero
al que la niña todo debe aguantar le el
fondo de esta historia es la isla una
dictadura sin dictadura pero sobre todo
rita que no es que sea escritora música
y activista sino que es eso y un
torbellino que además atraviesa al filme
con la canción regalito papis como jason
el de bien el estrés cuando uno menos se
lo espera se aparece yo a veces hasta
oigo la musiquita de terror me pongo muy
contenta
pero lo que más me parece propio jason
es que se aparece cuando
[Música]
rita indiana es en sí misma un multi
género artístico que nos conduce a la
evidencia de que la cultura ya no son
disciplinas estancas que una plataforma
de música en streaming como spotify
también puede ser una audio serie de
ciencia ficción llamada caso 63 es una
producción chilena que desde casa ha
transformado el desarrollo actoral y de
creación narrándonos el vínculo entre
una psiquiatra y un paciente que desde
el 2022 dice venir del año 2000 62
haciéndonos dudar de la realidad una
misión en el pasado debo evitar que ella
al evitar que tome un avión para cambiar
el futuro de la humana
en el futuro no tiene emocionado una
realidad que hoy también muta en los
videojuegos declarado nuevo escenario de
la música advertimos que el género iba a
marcar esta crónica y este está incluso
en juegos como minecraft o four night
este año hubo un festival de electrónica
en el primero mientras que en el segundo
artistas como el rapero travis scott o
el reggaetonero james balbín lideraron
conciertos con avatares en menor grado
los límites también se desdibujan con
jaden smith componiendo la banda sonora
de marvel se spider-man para playstation
[Música]
muchísimas gracias por la compañía
cuídense y sobre todo vuelvan a la era
disco gracias
[Música]
el delantero
bueno
[Música]